uh this is very very interesting
president joe biden
is uh currently experiencing
the highest initial approval rating of
any
president dating back 28 years
to bill clinton in 1993. the
uh all-america economic survey
has found that joe biden has a 62
approval rating right now his initial
approval rating
that beats the first presidential rating
of barack obama
of george w bush of bill clinton and of
course
of donald trump and in fact joe biden's
initial
rating of 62 approval is 18 points
higher
than that of donald trump uh there are a
number of takeaways here
first of all when we look at these
numbers
and understand that there are
hyperpartisan
um enclaves of americans that will
either always approve or always
disapprove of a president
merely based on political party you
realize that the real range it's not
really zero to a hundred
it's probably more like i don't know 20
to 80 or 25 to 75 or whatever so
when you see a rating of 36 that is
much closer to the bottom than it would
seem
because some portion will always approve
of the president
when you see a number like 62 that's
much closer to the top
because because some portion will always
disapprove so number one
the difference between 62 and 36 is much
bigger than merely the difference
between the two numbers when you
understand american politics that's
number one
number two important takeaway is that
this really reinforces that donald trump
could have easily won reelection
if back in march he had simply said
this is serious the doctors know what to
do
let's do what they say oh they say wear
masks we are printing
american flag masks do the patriotic
thing
if trump and his uh um staffers would
were
regularly pictured from the beginning
with the patriotic american flag
masks i know that might violate flag
code okay don't email me about that
um donald trump would have sailed to
re-election as we saw so many world
leaders do
who uh dealt with the virus well and
that is confirmed by uh this this
polling much of joe biden's early
approval
is based on his handling of the
coronavirus on which he has a nearly 70
approval rating so trump could be
president right now and it's because of
trump
that he is not we'll continue to follow
joe biden's approval
it could go up it could go down i really
don't know these are unique
circumstances in which we find ourselves
but i want to hear from you where do you
believe joe biden's approval will go
and or does it depend on accomplishing
something
like for example getting the coveted
relief checks to americans i believe if
he fails to do it
it will be a political disaster but i do
believe he is going to do it
let me know your thoughts i'm on twitter
at deep hackman
one of our sponsors is magic spoon magic
spoon breakfast cereal
sweet and delicious like the cereals you
had as a kid
without the sugar magic spoon tastes
exactly
like the cereal brands we all know and
loved as kids
but it has no sugar only three net carbs
and
13 grams of protein perfect for anyone
following a
keto or low carb diet or just anybody
wanting to eat less sugar comes in
frosted fruity cocoa
and their all new flavor peanut butter
that's my favorite magic spoon flavor
or you can get a variety pack so you can
try all four
magic spoon is so confident in how
delicious their cereal
is they'll give you all of your money
back if you don't
absolutely love it they'll give you five
dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video